we'd like to begin today's webinar by
introducing our speakers today first we
have professor bill Burnett who's a
consulting assistant faculty member in
mechanical engineering and is currently
the executive director of the design
program he manages our undergraduate and
graduate programs and design at Stanford
both joint programs between mechanical
engineering and the art department in
addition to his duties at Stanford he
serves as a board member of d2m a
product design consultancy Delson energy
and advises several internet startup
companies on design strategy welcome
bill I'd also like to introduce
professor Sherri Shepherd for mechanical
engineering who is also the co-director
of the Center for design research sherry
is also the Carnegie Foundation
advancement of teaching consulting
scholar principally responsible for the
preparations for the professions program
engineering study the results of which
are in the full report educating
engineers designing for the future of
the field besides teaching both
undergraduate and graduate design
related classes at Stanford she conducts
research on the development of academic
and career interests and aspirations of
college students and early career
professionals welcome Sherri and with
that I'd like to turn it over to Bill
well good morning I'd like to welcome
everybody to our webinar and we'll start
talking about innovation you know we use
the term innovation design thinking and
the notion of designing for change
almost interchangeably and this notion
of design thinking or using the methods
that designers use when they're
designing objects or services or
experiences in a more general sense to
design strategies or business objectives
this thing we call design thinking so
started at Stanford David Kelly who's
the founder of I do when I probably the
premier product development and
innovation firm in the world and also
the founder of our new Graduate
Institute the d.school
was quoted as saying we believe the next
generation of innovators and leaders
need to be great design thinkers this is
true whether you're in the design role
or in a business role in a program
management role or any place where
you're you're asked to come up with new
ideas and change something because
whenever you change anything you're
actually doing design you may be doing
design well you may be doing design
instinctively you may be doing design
accidentally but when things change you
are designing design thinking is a
process and it has and we break it in
two steps the first step of which is we
call empathy or empathize it's a deep
dive in the sort of human need that
surrounds the problem or generates the
problem there's an empathize step
there's a defined step there's an old
saying that a problem well defined as
half solved and we spend a lot of time
framing and reframing problems based on
the nuanced data that we get from our
empathy with users ideation or ID aiding
which is just the process of having many
many ideas you have to have lots and
lots of ideas if you want to choose a
good one you never go with your first
idea and then fundamental to our process
is we believe that you build your way
forward you don't sort of think or
decide your way forward design works on
the kinds of problems called wicked
problems where there really is no one
right answer
there are many answers that can be
optimized around different objectives
and you can never know fully all the
boundary conditions of the problem
you're working on because you're working
with humans you're working in complex
systems and some of the the biggest
issues are hidden until a solution
emerges and so we believe unlike
business thinking where you sort of
optimize between an A and B solution or
engineering thinking which we do a lot
of as well where you isolate you know
the dependent independent variables and
solve the equation design thinking is a
process where you don't decide or
analyze your way forward you build your
way forward we do this through a process
called prototyping and testing actually
prototyping testing and then we
prototyping and testing constantly
putting things in the world
the users to engage with and to get the
feedback that you need to understand
what are the true boundary conditions of
the problem prototyping is also a way of
creating alignment between yourself and
your users yourself and your management
team this is what we're actually doing
that what you thought we were doing in
the slides you saw and also between
yourself and the team that you're
working with so prototyping is a way we
say of creating a social space a space
in which all of those people can
interact with the potential design
solutions the problem with this of
course is that there's lots of processes
in the world and a process diagram like
the one I just showed you doesn't really
capture the nature of what design and
innovation is all about I love this
quote culture eats process for lunch it
came from Alan Mulally from it and it
was actually quoted by but this is the
CEO to one of our big school professors
he said he was walking through a
lunchroom and one of the young engineers
had put this quote up in a big printout
hanging on the wall it just is a kind of
little piece of you know radical
performance art or something inside Ford
and this came in response to a number of
attempts by Ford in the early days of
its turnaround to sort of reinvigorate
the company by changing their processes
they would get a consulting firm in and
they'd try to analyze why they weren't
building good cars and why they were
underperforming in their market and they
would change their process they would
add in a new step for conceptualization
or they'd add in another step for
validation and then when that process
failed to evoke the results that they
were looking for they'd hire some more
consultants and they'd say oh well
you've got the wrong process and they
would put in another process and once
the CEO saw this code he realized he was
managing the wrong thing you got a man
the most important thing you can manage
in any organizations and you have made
levers to pull you can manage the
financial health of an organization by
looking at the numbers you can manage
the process health of an organization by
looking at process but the number one
thing particularly as CEO manages is the
culture and Malay Li's changed the
culture from a culture of process driven
soul list car making to a corporation
whose culture was all about cars again
you know here Ian reinvested in the
culture of a car culture people who
loved cars people who knew knew
instinctively the kinds of cars that
their customers would love and as you
know Ford is one of the few companies
that didn't take a bailout and is also
not one of the companies now that's
working really really well and so rather
than get into a big debate about whether
the design thinking process that I
outlined in the five hexagrams is really
you know complete or whether there's
another step in the beginning some
people put except in the front some
people put implement at the back rather
than getting to that conversation the
way we think about it nowadays is design
is a is a is a process but design is
also about creating culture design
thinking and innovation come out of a
culture that uses the methods of design
to create the conversation about what it
is that we're trying to do so we like to
think of it as well as being about
creating culture and that culture is
first a culture of radical collaboration
this is a slide if you see there's five
people in this slide and it doesn't look
maybe to be like these folks are doing
anything radical but the man on the
mirror right with the lovely head of
gray hairs Terry Winograd one of the
senior people in computer science one of
the inventors of human-computer
interaction and the gentleman and the
far left in the back is Bernie Roth
presser Roth
he's one of the senior professors in the
mechanical engineering school he's a
kinematics expert then scattered around
we have people from the design school
from school of him
management science and engineering these
are all folks from different parts of a
very siloed organization called Stanford
University but all working together on a
project and radical collaboration we
find is probably one of the number one
things that unlocks innovation in an
organization getting people out of their
discipline silos engineering marketing
sales administration manufacturing
whatever those silos are in your
organization and having them get
together and work on projects as equals
in an organizational structure that is
non siloed and project-based so part of
this it's actually a fairly it is fairly
radical for most organizations to allow
this to happen I have a young graduate
student of mine who's down working in a
aerospace company down in the southern
part of the US and she proposed a
actually proposed and then executed a
brainstorming session where revolve
radical things manufacturing and
engineering actually sat down together
to solve a problem the brainstorming
session was highly successful people
walked out of there very energized and
thought that this might be a fun new way
to work she was pulled in to the vice
president's office of her group her
engineering group and told if she ever
did that again she'd be fired so it is
difficult often because when people
collaborate across organizations power
shifts ultimately if a team like this is
enabled to to really work and execute on
their solutions they will be given not
only budgeting authority but authority
to redeploy assets like people and
materials and that threatens the culture
of most organizations but we find this
one thing a culture of radical
collaboration is perhaps the single
biggest thing you can do to kind of
awaken innovation is that your
organization I mentioned empathy before
and it's truly a culture of empathy
people you know people talk about being
close to the customer or understanding
you know their market we think it goes
much deeper than being close it truly is
an empathic relationship with customers
and we use the tools
cultural anthropology and ethnography to
do observation almost every you know
organization is solving a problem for
someone or some some group of people and
yet often when we talk to design teams
engineering teams sales teams their
connection to the customer is really
second hand it's do their distribution
or through their the buyers you know had
a there and delivery point and it's not
directly with customers customers can
help you co-create innovation but you
have to talk to them and and customers
can't tell you what they want because
they really only know what they have and
what you know what they what they would
prefer but they can't they can't predict
the future for you so you used to use
the techniques of ethnography
observation interviewing and and living
in their environment this isn't bringing
customers into a focus group situation
this is you know people in a radically
collaborating team all of them going out
and observing to look at that as I said
the nuance behaviors of customers and
it's through these empathic processes
that you get a data set of where the new
solutions might lie it's actually quite
powerful it's sort of subtle what's the
difference between you know being close
to your customer and being empathic with
them but it is it's really a quite a
major step when organizations decide to
use these tools to come up with new
ideas it's also a culture of ideas you
know we believe in in all of the
processes and we teach a lot of these
processes here at Stanford brainstorming
mind mapping morphological analysis
biomimicry we have a biomimicry lab here
of our biomedical lab where we use
nature as the inspiration for robotics
the ability to generate lots and lots of
ideas and that gets stuck on any one
idea is critical to this culture because
it generates the sense of great great
possibility
in the solution set and then a culture
of prototyping we've talked about this I
talked about this in terms of the
process diagram prototypes are not the
models that the engineering team builds
to validate a design our prototypes are
not just about things you can prototype
and experience there was a project with
the emergency room over at Stanford that
one of the classes did obviously we
can't be putting designers and other
people inside an emergency room and
messing up you know the hospital's
organization there but we were able to
prototype an emergency room through a
proxy many of the things that happened
in the emergency room have to happen
quickly and have to happen accurately
and there is a tremendous time
dependency and the proxy that looked
like a pretty good substitute for that
was the pit crew at a NASCAR race very
similar set of problems things have to
happen quickly they have to happen
accurately they have to happen without
without failure you can't have a tool
fail or you know someone not have a tool
when they need it and that turned out to
be a pretty good proxy in the learnings
in that situation that prototype were
able to be brought over to the emergency
room and you can prototype and
experience you can prototype a service
we've done prototyping of a redesign of
the Department of Motor Vehicles here in
California all of these things can can
and the prototypes again are not
necessarily supposed to be solutions
they're supposed to be the things that
ask good questions and create a social
space where the real nature of the
problem can be explored and new data
from the users can be elicited so we
really strongly believe in in the
prototyping culture and all of that
leads to essentially a culture that
creates creative confidence what we're
doing at the d.school for our Graduate
Institute is bringing students in from
the business school from the School of
Law the School of Medicine the School of
Education people who have had
essentially no design experience ever in
their lives and we're teaching them
these principles to design thinking and
and you know person after person is
walking away even after one 10-week
class or even or two 10-week class is
saying you know I've rediscovered my own
personal creativity I'm empowered again
to have ideas I understand how to
visualize those ideas to prototyping and
I believe I'm a better team member for
it and whether they go back to become an
investment banker you know from the
business school or to become a teacher
or an educator from the School of
Education they feel creatively more
confident and once you get an
organization or team in an organization
feeling this way watch out for the stuff
that they're able to do and once you
start to infect this kind of thinking
across the organization you really start
to see some big changes so again design
thinking stands for this sort of event a
very dynamic approach to problem-solving
because it works well in these poorly
bounded problems and it uses prototyping
an iteration but it's also really an
approach to problem finding the whole
idea of reframing problems based on a
deep dive with users is really all about
the problem finding partner but we're
pretty good at solving things most most
organizations are actually pretty pretty
effective at solving problems it's just
they're often working on the wrong
problem or only a piece of the real
problem they're working on symptoms and
so using ethnography empathic
observation and redefining the solution
space and using prototypes to provoke
latent needs is really all about problem
finding and then of course it's a it's a
new perspective on value creation
whereas value come from in the
organization we do a lot of value
optimization activities total quality
management and Six Sigma things like
that optimize the value of what we are
creating but the value creation comes
from focusing on these real and user
needs and that's where the high value
you know answers lie so that's that's
that's our sense of what design thinking
stands for both as a process and as a
culture now we want to I want to shift
over to this notion of getting the most
out of innovation and you know who are
going to be your peak performers in the
future
and and this leads into the research of
my colleague colleague Sherri Shepherd
this notion of radical collaboration
let's just start there you know working
across the silos and organizations
people who can who have the tools to
work on multidisciplinary teams that are
really empowered to create change so as
I mentioned before innovation always
resemble represent some change if you're
going to change something you're gonna
do design so we need to have an
organization where everyone in the
organization understands design thinking
principles and then we have this
interesting shift happening in the
workplace
the Millennials the sort of you know 20
to 30 year olds that are coming up in
the world coming out of the university
the people that we're educating they are
coming in the next decade they'll be
responsible there'll be a you know a
significant percentage of the new
workforce and they're going to be
responsible for most of the heavy
lifting these are also by the way that's
the same people who probably helped most
of us when we can't figure out our
Facebook page or we can't get our
Twitter account working or we don't
underst the most digitally literate
generation we've ever educated here at
Stanford are anywhere they have the best
facility with the new digital
communication tools of any generation
and what we've discovered in the
research that sherry is going to share
with you they are natural collaborators
they are bored with doing things in a
routine fashion and sort of crave
innovation and so we're proposing today
in this webinar that they are really the
underutilized weapon for peak
performance and getting the most out of
innovation in in almost any organization
and with that I'll turn it over to my
colleague Sherri Shepherd thanks Bill
it's great to be here and talk about
culture and the element of culture I'd
like to focus on is you know the people
who are on the team
and to the extent that there are
differences and different life
experiences and points of view that
really could be leveraged to make it
more innovative team so I'm going to
share some some definitions and these
are kind of generalities about
generational trends we all don't fall
particularly just in one grouping but
you know there is some some
center-of-mass around when you were born
and the experiences that you've had that
do set you on a track in terms of
expectations and here are some groupings
around mature silence individuals born
between 1928 and 1945 all the way up to
Millennials and and Bill you know as he
was said we're focusing on what do those
younger workers really bring to the
workforce that we could better take
advantage of the women our participants
range from very few who are in that
older generation to about 26% 25% in the
Millennials so some of you are
Millennials and some of you are in my
generation that the baby boomers what I
want to focus on is that last row that
you know every generation feels like
it's smarter than the next and I in some
ways that perhaps a hopeful hopeful sign
believing that they can can tackle world
problems
you also notice that the three older
generations have this strong work ethic
as saying that that's something that
makes them unique around generations the
thing I want to point out about the
Millennials is they don't necessarily
put that in their top distinct
distinguishing characteristics but they
do have this sense of being tolerant and
that really is one of the
characteristics that might be better
leveraged in terms of of teamwork in
terms of collaboration in terms of
ambiguity in terms of prototyping and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
in a moment
so that there might be a gap this was
actually from a webinar last year
showing the age gap of participants what
this means is how much older you are
then your average colleagues and/or how
much younger the bars below the line are
in
vigils that are much younger than their
average colleagues and on the left-hand
side those that are are older and what
it does show is that in general we tend
to work in heterogeneous groups in terms
of those those generational mixes so we
can't just expect that all of our
colleagues have had the same life
experiences so let's talk a locally here
actually to show some of the issues with
Millennials in terms of how they're even
conceiving of what career might be is
quote from a study that came out last
year by the Pew foundation and they
found that two-thirds of the Millennials
say it is very likely or somewhat likely
that they will switch careers at some
point in their work life which really
does represent a pretty radical change
from older generations in terms of their
conceptions of going with an
organization and investing in it and
staying it with it for a long time now
this quote could be a little bit scary
and that oh people will continue to
change jobs it also is a challenge to
say how can we create an environment
where in fact people want to have a long
longer term investment in in
contributing so that here's one of the
examples of differences in points of
view here are some other examples of
different experiences across those
generational groupings the one of the
rows is on learning styles will
reinterpret that in terms of working
styles how you like to work and the next
row after that is teaching styles and we
might reinterpret that as managing
styles how how these individuals might
be managed or supervised and what we
find is I'll compare the baby boomers to
the Millennials you could also do the
same comparison with Generation X and
the Millennials but what you notice is
is the baby boomers again my generation
working style is pay attention and work
hard work independently and just figure
things out just work at it by myself
until till I've got it the Millennials
are really
being educated in an environment are
really demanding and getting used to an
environment where there's frequent
interaction with faculty and peers and
so that problems are open-ended it's a
much more fluid dynamic sort of work
situation in terms of management styles
or teaching styles you know the notion
of just hearing a lecture and and having
it be absorbed was much more the norm
for the baby-boomers versus the
Millennials wanting an interactive
environment so the idea of a millennial
just sitting by themselves being told
what to do and going away and doing it
on their own is really not the norm that
they're used to in particularly in the
school environment let's talk a little
bit about you know these dichotomies of
old paradigms and new paradigms for
teaching or manage managing and I'll
just you know highlight a few of these
in terms of goals of the Millennials you
know the old paradigm might have been
you know that their goal is to complete
a set of requirements this newer
generation really is much more focused
on growth you know how can what I'm
doing now help me become smarter more
creative how does it fit into a longer
term plan which might seem like it's a
Tod with that you know notion of I'm not
necessarily going to a company and
expecting to be there for my career but
in fact they're thinking strategically
about their own lifelong learning and
how it helps them develop a career or
realize a set of goals a couple of
others relationships the old paradigm
might be the workplaces impersonal
informal or actually formal and now a
much more mindset around personal
transactions um you know having lunch
together doing things outside of work
and let's look at a couple of more the
old paradigm competitive or
individualistic among workers and this
newer generation is wanting to think
about teams and cooperative learning
climate I think this one's important old
paradigm on conformity and cultural
uniformity so how to have consistency
within the group
the newer generation really is thinking
about diversity cultural diversity and
and that that's something to actually
hold within the group instead of a pat
down and get rid of and finally the
notion of where the power lies you know
the old paradigm for managing is that
the faculty or the manager holds the
power and students or now these early
career professionals are increasingly
expecting that they are personally
empowered to take on more leadership
roles in terms of the projects they're
working on so let me tell you about a
little of the work that I've personally
been doing those other slides were from
the Pew study so we've been actually
doing interviews of early career
principally focused engineers to figure
out what's working for them and what
isn't and we've framed this around the
notion of what's supporting them what
are they seeing as their supports in
terms of their being able to contribute
to an organization and what is forming
barriers what's getting in the way of
them really being contributing members
and then we've looked at you know the
things that we're hearing from their
interviews and we've actually done
interviews of their managers and then
being able to group those supports and
barriers in terms of elements that are
at the company level so the organization
as a whole elements that are at the
manager level on so the smaller work
group and then even more in the work
group elements that that really come
from your colleagues and your peers
within your local team and this is a
larger paper that's referenced on the
bottom of the slide where one could read
about all of these supports and barriers
at these various levels what I'd like to
do is just focus on two of these and
give an example of problems at the
company level that are serving as
barriers for these early career
engineers coming up to speed or I will
use the word that's commonly used them
becoming socialized into an organization
and and sometimes called the onboarding
process and one I'll focus on our
problems with employee education and the
second is the the lack of camaraderie
with coworkers and the lack of team work
with coworkers
so the examples I'll give are actually
quotes in this kind of research you you
read interviews you code them you find
common threads and elements and and so
within that idea of a barrier around
education here's an example of what an
employee would say and this employee is
always wanting more of an overview more
overview tell me about the whole company
process and procedures and how they work
and this was a frustration where this
young engineer who'd been with
organization about a year had been given
a particular task
to achieve but at the same time he
really wanted to know how does that task
fit into how the company works what the
philosophy is of the company and so
while the company felt they were giving
him a good education and attending to
that in terms of giving him the nuts and
bolts of a particular process
they'd failed to really give him a sense
of how does that that thing he's working
on fit into the bigger landscape of what
the company was about we could go in
with more quotes and that paper has more
definition of that company level
education process but I want to give you
another taste around the issue of
co-worker teamwork and camaraderie so
this young engineer is really expressing
kind of the dichotomy or differences
they they felt within the school
environment in the work environment he's
saying maybe it's this feeling of in
school they teach you all about this
teamwork effort but then you come out
here and I don't feel like I'm part of a
team I don't feel like there's any kind
of teamwork thing everybody's got their
projects and that's all they're focused
on is that they need to take care of
this project and
to do this and don't bother me so you
know I think this young engineer was
feeling disappointment in that they'd
really been groomed and we're getting
excited about being part of that that
culture for instance that bill was
talking about and then they got their
task and we're not at all part of
something bigger than themselves the
second quote has some other feelings
expressed I work in a group and
essentially that is sort of a team but I
don't really feel a team atmosphere like
we're all working towards something
together the culture that bill was
talking about is very much where
everybody brings an essential piece to
it the diversity of backgrounds are
really a key element and yet this
engineer is really expressing that they
have their tasks and and again they're
not part of something bigger than just
what they are contributing so I could
talk a lot more about kind of these
differences between Millennials and
other generations we do know a lot about
the generational characteristics both
from a teaching and learning standpoint
but also from a managing and workgroup
tatts standpoint there are some gaps
differences in expectations among the
groups but there are really some
potentially good leverage points with
the Millennials they are really
increasingly used to working on teams
it's becoming part of their educational
process they're interested in
collaborative work where they see that
various individuals uniquely bring
different points of view to the problem
that makes a solution better so they
want to engage in this work and yet in
the workplace there sometimes facing a
counterculture if you will that doesn't
want the team effort being there or the
collaborative work and there's a
disappointment so this really does
represent something for companies to
look at in terms of really how to take
advantage of what this younger
generation is bringing with them in
terms of how they want to how they want
to work well thank you sherry and Bill
um you know before
get into a little bit about how you can
learn more I'd like to encourage you to
continue asking questions we've been
seeing them come into the queue but
we'll be hosting a question and answer
period with Bill and sherry at the end
of the webinar today so please continue
to ask questions while I give you a
little bit more information at the
Sanford Center for professional
development we've been delivering
education to industry for over 40 years
and so we have reasonable experience in
creating educational programs to address
the career long learning needs of
professionals managers and executives in
industry we at Stanford are pleased to
be offering the Innovation Master Series
and partnership with faculty like Bill
and sherry for three days senior faculty
will lead you through hands-on workshops
where you will learn the problem-solving
tools and problem finding frameworks
that lead to innovation and strategic
leadership pioneered by the Design Group
and the d.school
at Stanford we designed this program for
managers business leaders and
decision-makers faced with the daunting
task of retooling and revitalizing their
enterprises here you can get a sense of
who might benefit from attending and as
bill mentioned anyone ranging from
project teams to innovation leaders etc
can really benefit from the content here
we've created this program because we've
been hearing how organizations struggle
to make innovation routine for quite
some time in today's business
environment companies continue to be
challenged to implement more projects
with fewer resources here you can see
some of the key takeaways that can help
you navigate tomorrow's business
challenges to impact the long term
success of your organization one of the
most unique aspects of the program is
that you will get the opportunity to
engage with the who's who line up with
faculty from the Stanford design group
and the D school who would pioneer
design thinking to solve today's wicked
problems like the challenges you heard
from Bill and sherry today so now we'd
really appreciate your feedback on this
poll if you could please take a moment
to indicate your interest and the
innovation master series it would be
really great okay excellent thank you so
much and with that I'd like to move on
to our question and answer session
some of these questions are better
answered orally so the first question
here is in a large organization usually
the empathy process is done by the
customer department and it's far away
from the design department and sometimes
the information doesn't flow between
those two very well yeah this is a
classic example of sort of siloed
organizations and I'm not sure who
exactly the customer department is
sometimes that's customer service
sometimes that's marketing if you're
looking forward a new product
development and you know this is the
classic game of telephone right where
somebody says something to somebody just
says something to somebody or and then
by the time I get it in design or I'm
trying to come up with a unique new
solution I don't even really understand
who I'm dealing with this is also you
know this is this is just the common
failure mode people try to capture the
insights from customers in a marketing
requirements document or a customer
requirements document and then then the
design team or engineering team responds
with an engineering response document
and we go back and forth and back and
forth and somewhere in that whole
process that what I call by nuance data
set the latent needs the things that
people can't tell you but they show you
are lost
look customers can't come up with a
brand new idea for you customers no
amount of customer research will develop
an iPhone and Apple is famous for saying
oh we don't do customer research we just
know what people want we just give them
insanely great wonderful things and then
they just buy them far that's true they
do make some insanely great wonderful
things but I was at Apple for seven
years and I can tell you that Apple does
more research with customers than any
company I know of not about what is the
new product we should do it didn't take
too much of a genius to figure out that
they should probably do a phone and get
him to mobile you know
smartphone applications because that's
that's the future and if you actually
think about it Apple in the last five
years has only done two new products a
phone and a pad everything else is the
line extension so apple doesn't do
research about whether people want a
phone from them but once they've decided
to do a phone to make it as easy to use
and
insanely great as Steve wood would say
it should be they do countless hours of
work and the design team is observing
directly how people use the phone what
their what their consternation czar why
they can't make something work or how to
make something even easier to make
something as simple and as easy as the
interface on and most Apple products
takes years and years and years of work
with customers so you cannot to do that
kind of work you cannot have this gap
between whatever the customer department
is and whoever is implementing the
design of new products because all of
the all of the important data that does
not you know people want to ports and
they want you know this many gigabytes
and that biggest screen another that so
that's easy you can capture that in the
document but the part that's really
critical that that grimace on someone's
face when they try to do something and
it doesn't work that will be lost and
you will develop you know subpar
products and services if you if you
don't do the radical collaboration and
this is where the radical collaboration
is hard because it means someone in the
customer department is going to have to
collaborate and take feedback from and
modify the stuff that they do because
someone from service or sales or
manufacturing or design was in the group
with them thank you Bill so our next
question is do you believe that this
process is equally applicable to
communication design again here meant
when I take this one communication
design and branding and advertising and
all of the work around marketing and
communication actually we find that
those are the teams that most readily
flip to being Design Thinking style
teams because they're already used to
the creative processes they probably do
a lot of brainstorming and a lot of
visual creativity to come up with their
new ideas and so it's just a matter of
connecting them more directly to the
not ethnographic practices and
observational practices that can really
empower their thinking with new ideas so
I think it works with communication
design I mean it works essentially again
if you're going to change your business
strategy if you change your the way you
make money you are redesigning something
and so all of these principles work
across the board in almost any of these
business disciplines thank you both so
our next question is this research
global and does it cover cross-cultural
issues or is this just based on
Millennials who are born in the United
States the work that I presented is
principally focused on millenials born
in the US I think many of the underlying
questions about the educational
framework and the cultural expectations
the same questions apply the answers may
be different and I think we're really in
a pretty dynamic shifting environment
where the idea of the Millennials if we
use that around when people are born and
we recognize for instance our workforce
now may have someone who was born in
those years but actually grew up in
China or India or Japan and so they're
going to bring again different
expectations I think the underlying
message is figure out what some of those
motivations are of the people who you
want to be in a team so that in fact you
can leverage the particular assets they
may be bringing into play I just wanted
to build on that we do have a class here
called cross-cultural design one of the
other professors professor Heinz and
professor Banerjee teach that class and
it's a class where we're doing design
thinking half the classes in the u.s.
half the classes in Peking University in
in Beijing China we do find that there
are some significant cultural
differences particularly around the
brainstorming and other processes which
rely on a kind of non hierarchical
everybody's idea is good everybody can
build on the ideas of others
and particularly in more hierarchical
cultures Asian cultures it's a fairly
difficult translation and so you know
we're working on evolving modified tools
for brainstorming in situations where
it's actually a pretty big issue to have
a manager who's believed in a top-down
hierarchical culture is supposed to have
all the good ideas to create a process
where people can still have ideas and
open and kind of unframed way without
any loss of face for people in the
hierarchy but um in general of you know
these be there there are differences
culturally but as sure mentioned the
studies are done in the US and they were
done with multicultural you know
engineers having what half of our
graduate students now come from outside
the US great thank you
so our next question here is I thought
that Generation X was defined by
quote-unquote slackers but yet you
mentioned that they were praised for
their work ethic just curious if this
perception has changed or if they've
just grown up good question and those
characteristics were actually generated
by that individual group themselves at
the time of the survey in 2009 2010 so
this was Generation X as forty-something
saying what is their unique
characteristic relative to the
generation that's older or the
generations that are younger so so it
does seem that Generation X now as
30-somethings 40-somethings see
themselves as as being in there with
that work ethic even though they may
have been perceived by others when they
were younger as being slackers great so
so what is a good way to introduce
design thinking into your workplace so
that others can see the practical
benefits and not just wave it off as
another business fad yeah the whole
business fair thing is a real danger and
I worry sometimes
because we've we talked about design
thinking so much that it can be
perceived as just another you know
repackaging of some old ideas I think
it's actually more substantial than that
but you know it's it's reasonable for
people in an organization say we'll show
me why should I change this is just you
know I have what we're doing may not be
working well but we know how to do it
our suggestion and we've seen this be
successful again and again is you can't
change an organization overnight you
change it project by project pick a
high-impact project project that has
significant rewards of successful and
significant downside if it's if it fails
you can't pick a project nobody cares
about because those are just doomed you
know to be boring no matter what I have
to pick a high-impact project that has
you know a reasonable importance to the
organization assemble a truly
multidisciplinary team not not the task
force of the people who have nothing
else to do or the people that are aren't
aren't important enough to stay on their
jobs I'd like to think of it as a great
jazz trio or jazz quintet you know pick
the Miles Davis the Dizzy Gillespie you
know the de Brubeck of your
organizations and put a really good band
together find a hard problem empower
them to you know command the resources
and and time that they need to do it and
then you know see what kind of a success
they have and expect that along the way
they will prototype many many many
things to fail we believe in failing
often to succeed early or and let that
let that process unfold predictably we
think you will end up with a success or
a nonlinearly new solution a solution
you would not have expected and then you
know spend some time reflecting on how
was that different than the way other
projects normally go what was unique
about it where did it work where did it
fail we find that if you can infect an
organization with one or two successful
projects organized this way rather than
around functions the people start to see
the benefits you also
the people will be threatened by the
fact that you know the power structure
has changed and the people who are not
in the functional organization have
authority to spend money and move
resources around but normally you'll
you'll notice the quantitative change in
the output an interesting innovation
that was not expected and a group of
people who are really excited about a
new way of working thank you um so since
many of our teaching and managing models
have been designed by either baby
boomers or Gen X do you believe that
these may not sort of feel the needs of
Millennials um so so I think that it's a
good point that the new tools the new
strategies have been in fact created and
designed by baby boomers and Generation
X and I would say actually underscoring
a lot of that design work on these new
models is a whole field called the
learning Sciences where we're really
understanding much more that people
don't learn particularly effectively by
believing that we kind of opened their
brain up and pour stuff in and learning
happens there's a much more nuanced
understanding of the learner actually
needing to be engaged and having to
struggle with the ideas along the way
and the need for scaffolding of the
challenges that are given to a student
so those learning science backgrounds
have informed what these baby boomers
and Generation X have done in terms of
creating new models a couple of things I
would add to that it's not ubiquitous in
terms of teamwork being part of a
student's experience in every class the
reality is that some students
engineering students may just get to be
doing some design their final semester
of their senior year whereas other
programs have really embraced the idea
of needing to do design and iterate on
it and make
makes and try doing design again from
the beginning of the freshman year to
the senior year so one thing I would say
is is the models haven't really gotten
into fully into every program and you
know I do think they feel the need of
Millennials now I want to talk a little
bit more about the managing aspect of
this or how it might play out in the
workforce these Millennials want to feel
that their work is important you know
that they really are doing something
that it's critical for themselves
critical for the organization they're
working with and will have a more global
impact at the same time they need
scaffolding in the work you know that
they're not equipped to come in and be
challenged with something and say well
go out and figure this out over the next
six months so how do people as their
supervisors and managers give them
enough input in direction to not do
micromanaging it but to be pushing them
or urging them or coaching them or
mentoring them whatever descriptor you
want to get so that they can figure out
what resources they need to bring to
bear to take on this task that they've
also gotten a sense of is important to
the organization I think we have more to
do in terms of thinking about those
teaching and managing models but I
really do think some of the things we're
seeing in terms of the learning
environment really do have contraction
in terms of the work world great so our
final question how would you compare the
Roger Martin School of thought on design
thinking with what's being taught at
Stanford
that's ideas school of thought yeah this
is a great question for a couple of
reasons first of all Roger Martin is the
Dean of the Rotman School of Management
at the University of Toronto and he's
written a fantastic book actually
mentioned the book in a webinar we did
last month it's called the design of
business and Roger has has been quoted
as saying it shouldn't be a Masters of
Business Administration which is simply
the you know caretaking of something it
should be a master of business creation
or business design MBD and Roger
and we are great friends he's been out
to speak to Stanford a number of times
and David Kelly and some of our other
professors have been have spoken at the
Rotman school so there is actually
really no difference in the underlying
philosophy by the way this notion of an
ideal school of thought I like to think
of ideas our best little startup David
Kelly was a grad student when I was a
senior here many years ago and created a
company based on all of the work that
the founders of the design program at
Stanford a guy named Bob McKim another
guy named Ralph frosty who took took it
on later have generated so almost all of
these ideas that you know our sort of I
do I bet I was taken out into the world
really were generated here first but
Rogers um Roger if you if you're
interested in a great business book on
design thinking the design of business
is is probably the best and what he does
is reframe some of our ideas more into
business concepts that might might that
translation of language might make it
more more acceptable or easier for you
to explain it to folks in the boardroom
he talks about you know an idea funnel
going from you know sort of big ideas to
heuristics to rules and when in the
process do you want to use design to
change the heuristics and so I highly
recommend a book Roger is a great
thinker he's also publishing quite a bit
there I forget the name of the rotman
schools magazine but they have a
business publication magazine much like
the Harvard Business Review and it's got
some of the best research work on how
Design Thinking can penetrate
organizations and how the implementation
occurs so I highly encourage you to look
at his stuff well thank you again
villain sir I think it was a great
presentation and we also appreciate all
of the great questions that you've
submitted what we'll do is there's still
a few questions in the queue and so our
presenters will be hanging out to answer
those after the webinar I just want to
close here's some information here with
some dates June 15 to 17 will be hold
the innovation master series that I
referred to and there's an early
registration deadline there of April 8th
as well as some contact details for our
associate directory buyer who's managing
that efforts so thank you again for
joining us and we'll be answering all
the remaining questions in the queue bye
bye